we film everything and we try to show as
much as we can in 44 minutes once a week
on a one horse show hold on tight guys
it's the one hour show that keeps on
giving it's really hard to regain trust
you're one stupid weekend you just
demolished a relationship keeping up
with the kardashians has a new teaser
for season 16 and we're hearing khloe
kardashian seemingly sound off on x
tristan thompson cheating scandal well
the first one when she was pregnant with
their daughter true
motherhood just puts life into
perspective and what's important to you
what I think you just re-evaluate things
it's a full-time job warning off the
negative people I'm not gonna be nice
there's no telling if the Kardashians
had time to include the latest drama
with Tristan and Jordan Woods allegedly
making out but there's plenty of feuds
and heated topics to talk about it's
been a really rough week in our home in
Calabasas Hidden Hills and our neighbors
and Thousand Oaks in Malibu
keeping up will also show how the family
came together during the devastating
California wildfires as flames and
during my property Kim's houses on fire
or evacuating this is like unreal and
emotions are high for the sisters just
like every season
it's exciting that's always to do some
with the family well not this time kiddo
Jenner might be distancing herself from
Kourtney after another sister fight
Kendall's like very uptight but you did
some not cool things I'm just gonna be
like a loan to no one's surprise there's
lots of drama to keep up with when the
show returns on March 31st we try to get
in there as much as we can that we know
that everybody will love and it's just
so good
[Music]